في الوقت الذي تنهال فيه الانتقادات على
النظام الايراني كشفت ايران انترناشونال
خبايا جديده عن الحرس الثوري تحديدا عن
ميليشياته في المنطقه حادثه فساد داخل جسم
الذراع القوي للمرشد كشف تفاصيل
النظام كشف النظام او حاول النظام ان
يخفيها طويلا كشفت الان مساعد رئيس
البرلمان الايراني جمال الديناب رومانسي
استولى على جزء من رواتب الميليشيات في
العراق وسوريا واليمن لكن النظام الايراني
لم يسعى الى محاسبه
ولا محاسبه مشتركين معه في هذا التلاعب
بحسب ايران انترناشونال فان فيلق القدس
التابع للحرس الثوري الايراني لديه اكثر
من 200 الف مقاتل في الشرق الاوسط لكنه
يعلن انهم نصف هذا العدد فقط تحصل ميليشيا
حزب الله اللبناني على اعلى الرواتب بنحو
1300 دولار شهريا مقدمه من النظام
الايراني لكل عنصر مقاتل
راتب ميليشيات ايران في سوريا فيبلغ 250
دولارا بينما ياتي الحوثيون في اليمن في
ذيل القائمه بنحو 100 دولار شهريا لكل
مقاتل